more trouble for a draft law to give
Member States imposed to genetically
modified food and feed the right to
prohibit their import Parliament's
Agriculture Committee added its voice to
calls for the European Commission to
redesign its proposal why because MEP
say it violates sacred principles of
free competition II just wanted the
Andhra legal on the swedish fish toyota
page needy does venom try and pin on my
club with the hiding in chatham is
described in the mark of / photo Malika
second we cannot leave the member state
to introduce the limitation of barrier
to the utilization of GM because they
will have a job part i sat the European
market on this Germany France and Greece
are among those most opposed to GM
products Britain Spain and Belgium among
those more open with growing populations
and pressure on food it's time says mr.
de Castro for different thinking
probably in the future we will never see
any frankest and food because the new
technology move the gene inside of the
species so without any movement between
spaces so this change the scenario so I
think we need more knowledge more
research Parliament is due to vote on
the issue in November
you